this gorge  is where all lions come to find their  raw alliance even my dad even Mufasa  came here when he was your age  refused to leave until his roar could be  heard above the rim all the way up there  that's when you know you found it for  the little practice you'll never be  called a cub again watch this  you'll get it Simba just takes time I'll  check on you later dad would be so proud  Ronny it's a gift he'll never forget  life's not fair  visit my little friend while some are  born to feast others spend their lives  in the dark  [Music]  begging for scraps  everything you see  exists together in a delicate balance  [Music]  while others search for what they can  take a true king says as the what he can  do  [Music]  way Simba  never return  you must take your place  [Music]  and the circle of life  [Music]  you